[MUSIC PLAYING]
JESSICA: Hi.
I'm Jessica.
And today, I'm going to be
talking about a chemical
demonstration I like to
call " "Mirror, Mirror."
In this demo, MIT'S
Dr. John Dolhun
will demonstrate Tollens'
Test, a chemical test created
by this man, Bernhard
Tollens, a German chemist born
in the late 1800s.
So let's watch Dr. Dolhun
perform this demonstration here
at MIT as part of the
Cambridge Science Festival.
JOHN DOLHUN: OK, so I'm
going to be careful.
And I'm going to pour my first
substance into the flask.
My second substance,
down to the last drop.
And my third substance.
And we're going to
do a little shaking.
We're mixing some
things together.
JESSICA: So what
did Dr. Dolhun do?
Well, he added three
solutions to the flask.
Solution 1 was glucose in water.
Solution 2 was a mixture of
silver nitrate and ammonium
nitrate.
And Solution 3 was sodium
hydroxide, which is a base.
So let's focus on the
second two solutions first.
When you mix solutions 2
and 3, two things happen.
First, you form Ag2O, which
is insoluble in water.
So it precipitates
out as a brown solid.
The sodium hydroxide reacts
with ammonium and H4 plus
to produce ammonia, NH3.
This dissolves the precipitate.
And you end up with Ag(NH3)2,
which all has a positive
charge.
This is soluble in water, and
it's called Tollens Reagent.
Now, the positive charge
is borne by the silver.
So what we have in solution
is essentially silver ions.
Now looking at Solution 1,
glucose looks like this.
We don't really care about this
whole part of the molecule.
So we're going to call
it R for "the rest."
So glucose is basically this.
And this part of
the glucose is going
to start reacting
with the silver ions.
Let's watch what happens.
JOHN DOLHUN: I don't
see anything happening.
Do you?
OK, still working on it.
I'm getting tired here.
Something happening?
AUDIENCE: It's silver.
It's
JOHN DOLHUN: Oh, my
goodness, I can see myself.
Well, this is a real
workout, I'll tell you.
So what we've created
here is a beautiful silver
mirrored flask.
JESSICA: So look at that.
Dr. Dolhun has created a
beautiful silver mirror.
It almost looks like a
Christmas tree ornament.
And a silver ornament could,
in fact, be made this way.
So here's what's happening.
Electrons from
here, the glucose,
get transferred to the silver,
reducing it to silver zero.
Silver zero is
insoluble in water.
It's just silver metal,
and it's precipitating out
on the inside of the flask,
forming the beautiful silver
mirror that we see.
Now, this process is
called "reduction."
And whenever
something is reduced,
something else is oxidized.
So the glucose must
be getting oxidized.
It becomes this.
An oxygen was added here.
Now, this process is similar
to metabolism in our bodies.
We remove electrons
from the sugar we eat,
and transfer them to the
oxygen that we breathe.
In a reduction reaction
like mirror, mirror,
there might be energy released.
In your body, this energy is
harnessed in chemical bonds,
stored for later.
The point of Tollens' Test was
not to produce silver mirrors,
although a similar reaction
is used for that today.
The point was to distinguish
between two types of sugars--
ones containing aldehyde
and ones containing ketones.
Let me draw those.
The difference is
that in an aldehyde,
the carbon is connected to
a hydrogen. And in a ketone,
the carbon is connected
to another carbon.
Aldehydes are more
reactive than ketones,
so they will react
with the silver ions,
while the ketones will not.
That's it for me.
Hopefully, you
enjoyed this video.
And I will see you next time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]